développés et moins développés,
il y a eu un partage de
compromis.
Voici un résumé de cette longue
nuit.
de la biodiversité.
mondial pour la protection
- Danse, dodo, tricot :
la soirée a été longue,
très longue. Puis, le dénouement
tant souhaité est survenu
aux aurores, en seulement
quelques minutes.
Le président de la COP15
a proposé l'adoption du cadre
mondial pour la protection
de la biodiversité.
Une proposition immédiatement
appuyée par le Mexique.
"Un texte parfait, ça n'existe
pas. La perfection est l'ennemie
du bien", lance la déléguée. P s
ont voulu exprimer
leur mécontentement.
- Je suis obligé de vous dire
que les consignes qui étaient
les miennes, au départ de ma
capitale, sont bafouées. Et je
voudrais exprimer ma déception.
- Le président a entendu
les doléances et a jugé que
le consensus était atteint.
(applaudissements)
Le cadre mondial Kunming-
Montréal est donc adopté.
Un cadre que plusieurs
qualifient d'historique.
STEVEN GUIULULULT, min. fédéral
Environnement et Chang. clim.
- On a finalement le moment
Paris pour la biodiversité ici
à Montréal, et on a maintenant
l'entente... le cadre mondial
pour la biodiversité Kunming-
alalalal. C'est un moment
vraiment historique.
CHRISTOPHE BÉCHU, ministre
français Transition écologique
- Et à la fois des référen
aux pesticides. On évacue pas
la question des subventions
qui sont nocives pour
la biodiversité. Il y a
des engagements qui sont précis
avec... avec des dates.
- L'objectif phare de protection
de 30 % des terres et des océans
est enchâssé dans le texte, tout
comme l'obligation de réduire
de moitié les risques liés
aux pesticides. Et l'accord
avalise aussi la création d'un
fonds dédié à la biodiversité,
tel que souhaité par les pays
en développement. Équilibré,
empreint de compromisetetetetet.
Il faut le dire, la COP aura
été un succsisisisisi et surtout
grâce à la collaboration
exemplaire entre la Chine
et le Canada, un jeu
d'équilibriste dans le contexte
géopolitique actuel.
Ici Elisa Serret,
Radio-Canada, Montréa